Great editing environments,
safety nets in place?
>> Check and check.
What else could we need?
>> Well, we've optimized your
development workflow but
that's about it.
Now think about all
the things that you do or
should do after you finishing coding and
planning a release.
Things like unifying and
concatenating your source files and
optimizing your images.
In today's mobile world, you see
hundreds of different device, browser,
and screen combinations
that use your app or site.
In some cases, it's simply
impossible to optimize by hand.
>> This is where your
build process steps in.
We'll use it to optimize things
that you can't fix by hand, or
simply take too long.
And doing so
will make your build more powerful,
so that it takes a raw source code and
polishes it for production.